on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the veteran left-hander drew smiley
smiley 31 years of age he's in his
ninth year at the big league levels
three starts no record with an era of
2.9 3.94 but look at the strikeouts 27
and 16 innings
he has been outstanding
and this is fought off and it's looped
into left for a base hit so after going
over five last night and having his
nine-game hitting streak snap topia
looking to start another one as kevin
pilar comes up
and this ball is going to get through
that left side where three guys were
hanging out and the rockies had the
first two on to begin the evening
josh fuentes will try and knock home
those two base runners
line to left
and that's going to end the inning
smiley pitches through it rocky strand a
pair this will be start number 12. he's
got a 375 earned run average he has
eight
quality starts already yeah seven no
decisions for kyle so you got to go back
to august first for his last w that was
a game against san diego here's slater
the d.h tonight
slater drives one to left tapia looking
up
out of here
fifth homer in his 70th at bat and the
giants lead one nothing home run number
five
that's a two strike thunder right there
rockies find themselves down one to
nothing matt kemp the rockies d-h
tonight leads it off that is ball four
so cap walks
he's downstairs
and kept takes off
that surprising everyone the rockies
must have a read on smiley because
normally it's tough to run on lefties
and you know there was a day a time
where matt kemp was a huge threat to run
well that's just a straight straight out
steal that boy man watch him switch the
gloves from his left hand to his right
hand in the middle in the middle i've
never seen that
either
2016. that may be the last one he ever
steals hey it's 20 20. it's an odd year
you have to
appreciate the effort made by lucille to
entertain the cutouts
i mean he's working hard and every day
you know it's something new he's mixing
it up so i don't think that really works
unless you actually go in the water
well interesting the giants are putting
crawford in the game so crawford's day
office three-inning day off and that'll
bring up fuentes bart sets the target
here's the pitch fuente strikes out
swinging good curveball got him smiley
picks up his fourth strikeout not as
prolific with the strikeout stuff
tonight swinging a liner to short
crawford right there playing up the
middle catches it
out number three that one whistled past
smiley on its way up the middle four
five at six rough longoria dubon for the
giants
bouncer to the right side hampson shaded
up the middle makes the play and throws
on to first ruff retired 2-2
and
pop to short right blackman calls off
hampson
that's how it works to god one no on
dubai with two outs and nobody on
and this ball toward charlie again and
that's a quick inning robertson for the
giants against freeland it's one nothing
giants in the bottom of the fifth
robertson swings and hits a soft liner
into center field for a base hit here
comes joey bart who slide out to shallow
right center his first time
driven into left center field and
nobody's there is pilar is going to
watch this one bounce and flatten out
and here comes robertson and roberts is
gonna score and joey bart's got a double
in an rbi and the giants have a
two-nothing lead
and everybody knows he's been grinding
especially especially his fellow rookies
the rockies get men on the corners with
nobody out smiley has got charlie twice
struck him out on a curve ball and got
him on a ground ball to first
then charlie bounces it to the right
side the second is the only play they're
gonna get pilar scores to make it a two
to one giants advantage two outs pilar
coming up with tapia at first base
this ball lined the left in the corner
tapia flying toward third stu cole's
going to set them
topia heading home and he is in standing
up tie ball game what an at bat from
kevin pillar and here's trevor story
with pilar representing the go ahead run
at second that is top very softly third
base side going to be a tough play
rogers off the mount has it with the
bare hand throws to first and they get
the out there flores throws home and
they tag pilar at home trying to score
why not get as many outs as you can so
dickerson will get a chance to hit as he
stands in for his first at bat of the
night in a tie game
hit the center field
pilar back still back at the wall
out of here
alex dickerson's mastery of the rockies
astonishing what a big moment that is
three to two giants so it's aj ramos to
face brandon belt who's a pinch hitter
giants have first and third one out
leading by a run
belt it's a high drive in the left
center field pilar on the move it is off
the bottom of the wall slater read it
immediately
he's rounding third the throw home not
in time and belt with a pension double
to not get a pair